but to flip the tables on you
for uh hundreds of thousands i think
millions of people
i can speak me and them are really
grateful
one that you exist and two
sorry for your podcast
and i do hope your voice in some form
continues
to to reverberate
i think in the at least in the 2021s and
and beyond even if it takes a brief
pause
we're pausing at the moment we've
recorded some
for future episodes and i'm recording
for you i really appreciate that
i mean it's it's earnestness uh
trades at a discount at the moment
because it's easy to make fun of it one
of the things i like best about you is
that you and i are both fairly earnest
we made we made joke and jeb but
honestly there's a project here in a
world to win as they say
um the thing that uh
i want my and your listeners to know is
that i'm not stepping away
from the podcast because
i don't appreciate that people really
want more it's not
you know this is hugely financially
costly to me
um i want to make sure you guys are
getting
the best that i can do and
destroying myself right in front of an
election
i think lex is incorrect i think that
the forces that are trying to make sure
that there aren't any planes in the sky
that aren't either colored red or
colored blue
is a big danger given how angry i am at
the system
and i don't want to be removed from the
chess board because if nobody's going to
talk about jeff epstein there need to be
people if nobody's going to talk about
various things that we've talked about
on these programs i want to make sure
that i'm there
do i think that this is potentially an
existential election yes do i
am i positive that i know that my way to
bed is the right way out no i'm not
i don't know people i just don't know
and where we are
right now seems so dumb and so
catastrophic in terms of how it is
chewing up smart people
that i decided it's really not about
cowardice because
i it's hard for me to restrain myself i
have so many reactions every day
um this is really about trying to plan
for all of our futures to make sure that
i'm around
i had a huge concern that what happened
to brett's articles of unity was going
to happen to brett
what's going to happen to the youtube
channels i want to make sure that we
don't have all of our eggs in one basket
so if something goes wrong over there so
you know that's the whole idea of the
intellectual dark web which is at some
level
a loose confederation it can become a
strong confederation if somebody wants
to back it
and make it work it can dissolve so that
there really isn't anything um the thing
is to be hard to kill
because ultimately when the hit pieces
come
they don't come for what it is that
they're angry at you about they come for
when
when where they can get you and so it's
very important that right in front of an
election
um yeah i think that
the desire of the old system to defend
itself
through reputational destruction is one
of the most
pernicious aspects of the new america
and we have to fight
the ability to destroy reputations as a
means of institutions
keeping individuals with podcasts and
the ability to reach millions like
through substack
out of their domain i don't surrender
this domain to them they have
plenty of weaponry with which to fight
us and i believe that they could remove
you or me
in an instant by the end of today if
they wanted us off the chess board we
would be off the chess board i know
that's not your perspective
my goal is to stay here as long as
possible to make sure that you have
enough
of a counterbalancing set of ideas and
to and to let
and help other podcasters start
and my hope is is that that works but
you know long heroism short martyrdom is
a good
motto for anyone and i try to remember
the short martyrdom part of that
first of all beautifully put second of
all wait to end the conversation and the
disagreement
which is how you hook them for the next
conversation to be continued
when lex says eric
it's a huge honor thank you once again
lex really appreciate every time we get
together thanks buddy
you